I'm a professor at Fordham University in
this is my student on the data finance
program I teach simulations class and we
are going to present some tutorials that
students created as a project in their
simulation class sometimes the project's
go on and continue for a couple of
months so that's tutorials take some
time to complete we will start from a
tutorial on algo pie in then if we have
time we have a tutorial and logistic
regression now I will tell a little bit
about our educational approach how these
tutorials are organized and why we
decided to do tutorials it's through
tutorials students actually understand
better what's going on and also then
help pretty helpful to other students
now a little bit about our educational
approach ok boys ok ok do you hear me
yeah ok so there is a gel challenge to
teach machine learning methods as part
of simulations class it's a financial
masterson quantitative finance program
so it's graduate program people come
from different backgrounds mathematics
physics computer computer science and
would like very quickly to introduce
sento models in financial engineering
and so they can quickly start to use
software or develop their own software
mainly using a available software as
engineers
so usually our educational projects are
multidisciplinary it means it's a little
bit of mathematics a little bit of
financial modeling a little bit of
machine learning methods or global
optimization methods sometimes the same
methods are called black box
optimization because we deal with a
function which is not defined
analytically and then later I will talk
a little bit more about this in began
this tutorials are examples of student
work we welcome any comments because it
it's possible that we're missing some
something this tutorial should be
helpful to someone who doesn't want to
dip into how alga pie is created but how
to use it if they have a certain problem
material what problems can be stated as
problems of global optimization and this
is where approach the approach that we
use many models in financing and
actually in any type of engineering can
be formulated as problems of global
optimization where machine methods are
very useful machine learning methods and
very often target function is not
available analytically so you can also
see input and output sometimes it is
called black box functions the type of
project type of real-world work applique
tasks range from Robert parameter tuning
and optimization of chemical processes
the biological system analysis in
finance typical problems are model
calibration price engaging value at risk
and conditional Value at Risk
computation credit rating assignment
it's more kind of new route which is
also only possible with food
classification methods also free gifting
strategy optimization in electronic
trading systems and lot more the choice
of the algorithm for decision-making
should depend on the type of objective
function and availability of a priori
information as well as your user
constraints such as budget example
genetic algorithms work well on
multimodal smooth functions and does not
require information about derivatives
but is a very it was expensive to run
because it requires many function
evaluations as opposed to an elder and
middleware ism which requires only a few
function evaluations and does not
require derivatives information
but the problem with northern myth is
that it's not really global optimization
methods and say it's non-local but not
global and it requires frequent we start
to be able to search the whole domain I
think now we are going to so I have a
little more information about our
educational project but now we are going
to switch to tutorials and then if we
have time i will tell more about the
approach but mainly there yeah i will
maybe say a couple of more mean it I'll
take couple of monies for introduction
such problems are best approached with
the library of musician methods to help
study the nature of the problem as
opposed to one method because no one you
cannot say machine learning method is
good for everything it depends on the
problem several such libraries are
available such as matlab global
optimization tool box there are several
functions that we have many many
parameters by tuning up these parameters
you create hybrids and you get the whole
universe of different methods however
these modules are arrested in a church
and require the advanced knowledge of
the method to be able to use it we use
theoretical approach developed by one
professor ian watkins institute of
management sites science 40 years ago
actually it was a theoretical approach
now we can derive methods and build
software on this this approach also he
has a great educational value giving the
students a general roadmap rather than a
collection of heuristic methods to
understand global optimization better
typical settings and data analysis would
be you are given a table of inputs and
out in responses this is a setting for
regression for any type of aggression or
any type of course interpolation or many
other things so in many cases we deal
with this instead of analytical form of
the function we deal with the stables
this is a black box function he now
approached their building blocks almost
all algorithms global optimization
algorithms would be constructed from
this building blocks and the purpose
basically purpose of tutorials are to
walk you through this building blocks
and to understand them very well and to
seek work and they be inserted in your
not inserted how the optimization
algorithm can be built upon these pieces
so yeah okay ah yeah yeah well it will
send it it's not yet will will send it
afforded to tutorials we're going to go
through a logistic regression and out
you come implementing our algorithm my
appreciation you shall go pack you can
actually go to our github I yet so you
need to go online like tche are out
there are two tutorials and they are
posted as the public get published so I
think you can access if your Wi-Fi works
well let's longer recovery we can send
it we were told that we don't need to
upload it in advance so you listen and
then we'll send I'll go through the to
what we send it later for sure we
uploaded this is just an example how
black box function can be
given yep not a statistician but is this
related to avoid being overfitting this
is um so this curve ball curve is a
interpolation and dotted curve is
regression but this form of data could
be used for other settings as well this
is general framework for black box
function so you don't have analytical
form just in put it down and output
sometimes the small T dimensional in
many cases suggest a simple form so you
can depict it basically with this
picture I just wanted to show the data
how we define the data automatic
differentiation is a way for computing
derivatives of all the technically
defined functions and the theoretical
approach was developed maybe 60 years
ago but no one would take it as a
effective computer science though so it
wouldn't go into software and complete
two approximation methods of computing
derivatives or any other methods and now
it is fast enough so you can actually
take a video give adjust of a computer
code in we are going to see how it is
used to compute sensitivities of auction
prices this is a classical example from
financial engineering and financial
modeling were all students final
students what goes through black-scholes
pricing the why we we take black-scholes
pricing of European options because
analytical form is also available and we
can compare a number so it's really very
simple tutorial we compute
swiss automatic differentiation package
and then we compute them analytically
and see that this is the same there are
other building blocks were we don't have
tutorial on this but we plan to do this
household and transformation you can see
it an elder and method this is a diff
reaction of some basic step in northern
mid is a taking evaluating your function
in all the points and then take all the
point except the words one a beaut the
center of mass of these points and then
reflect the worst point about the center
of mass so you can't do a reflection
this is household the transformation and
then rotation of coordinate systems this
is also very good module which we are
going to hear a tutorial on soon because
it allows you to take maybe so
third-party organization software which
doesn't work well for a function and use
it in the other coordinate system this
is household the transformation this is
if you like you can try this as an
example from type i optimize the this
algorithm is implemented is a function
if mean actually in any software there
is a function there is an algorithm
implemented this algorithm is very
useful in many cases it does not require
derivatives derivatives of objective
function and probably the best choice
for function sighs abandon the function
this is a valley shaped function were
derivative based optimization methods
oscillate and don't work too slow
but this is an example from help on
optimize again today tutorial for
vulgarity differentiation computing
derivatives of organic locally defined
functions with a European option price
is an example because analytical
derivatives of this function is also
available what logistic regression will
be reduced in the tutorial from simple
examples and advanced tutorial is also
available but not online we're here with
this word file but I don't think we'll
have time but I can always send it if if
you like I think we can start a tutorial
and then we can share some more examples
okay this is a don't mean this is my
students from last year he created these
tutorials and also tutorial on Olga pie
was created with previous year student i
will probably will give you his email if
you have questions you can sense him he
didn't you couldn't come because he is
already working he's working the numerix
and it really takes a lot of effort to
do these tutorials but I think it could
I I think it's terrible tutorials giving
you this show you to tutorials and the
first one about algorithmic from
automatic differentiation is quite short
and Emily our focus on the application
in the field of finance and a little bit
about the theory part why people use
automatic differentiation we know there
are other two methods either numerical
differentiation so you find the limit of
the quotient this is used to commonly in
ok in the visit you use color commonly
but the disadvantage is sometimes you
have overflow or underflow another
method
to find derivatives is using a symbolic
actually I have I have done a project
using matlab there's also a symbolic
library but a thing is it gets really
really slow when you are found
especially like from second derivatives
like if you calculate housing matrix in
ml ye and you want to throw the Hessian
matrix or the Jacobian matrix into your
optimization function it gets really
slow so you just can't estimate even
it's very accurate oh and the second
tutor is about logistic regression is
rather lengthy because i want to show
how you can derive it from conditional
probability and how to use it in secular
so you can go to Wilson in sleeping yep
but you can go to try and just tape
record yep so you can go to this and
there are PI data logistic regression is
the second tutorial they occupied to
Atari the first one and you can paste it
into a notebook view / sir is this on
you know yeah it's got up Ric HD RL so
you don't need to download it you can
just access and you can paste it on the
view / okay so I'll just go through the
okay so this is an about application of
automatic differentiation in finance URL
okay if you want the URL check this 2x
but you don't need to do that you can
just copy via get ID into the unbeliever
so you just go to a Richter L yep yeah I
think some others know how to do it if
you can't help but these are that you're
out buddy okay I'll just go in the first
tutorial so so as I said automatic
differentiation or called algorithmic
differentiation is a technique to
evaluate relatives for a function so
let's start up with a warm-up example so
we want to to fund the derivatives of
this function for example so we
calculate derivatives analytically and
we want to fund up the Taylor series
about point a so a equals 3 and X of 3.5
these are the results calculated by hand
but you can also do it in using algo pi
which is a library to implement
algorithmic differentiation it's very
easy to adjust new to step so basically
the first step you define the function
and the second step is on this apartment
is about it's a little bit about the
special algo pi syntax I've recommend
you to read the there's documents
because there is a session about Taylor
series to calculate it you get the
result as follows you check with the
lamp pretty works pretty well so this is
a like a warm-up question warm-up
example and now we can use n up there's
a application
automatic differentiation in science
which is to calculate Greg's four
options there's a formula in the field
of finance especially in the field of
option market called black-scholes
formula yeah is this messy stuff is
basically derived from a stochastic
calculus so you assume the price of SF
follows out your matrimonial moshe you
don't really need to understand this but
if you are you're from the field and
finance you probably know this so option
traders really care about the
first-order sensitives from this messy
formula and second-order sensitives from
this messy formulas and erica and this
second derivatives and first order
derivatives are also called griggs for
the rhythm that they are denoted by brig
letters I don't know about Derek
albergues in finance so basically you
need to calculate this on this this
thing's so you can use it you can use
algo pipe to implement automatic
differentiation so as the previous
example of taylor expansion you define a
function and you calculate the
derivatives and for the first order
derivatives you can calculate in a badge
and then you can output in a Jacobian
matrix and for the second order
sensitive you can output to a has a
matrix but there's one thing to be noted
here because automatic differentiation
is based on chain rule so if you have a
function for example sine 2x you first
calculate the derivative of 2x and then
you Callie the sign sign a ww equals to
act since like a using the chain rule in
the calculus and not all the functions
can be accessed by a library i'll go pie
for example you can't use in this case
so the black-scholes formula here's the
big n denotes the normal cumulative
distribution function so you may think
about using a normal cdf from Sify
directly but you
in fact you have to develop them using
the used most of basic functions so the
standard weight is to use error function
to build the you should roll your own
and build your own normal community test
of distribution function in this section
and after you have your own normal
normal function you can define another
function to store the black-scholes
formula so this function CX c stands for
the price of your option contract so
this function is about black-scholes
formula so now you have everything you
have the function all you need to do is
to calculate Jacobian matrix the syntax
here is very easy you just any Jacobian
at four starting points and the extra
Jacobian matrix the output is here for
the Hessian matrix or the second order
Griggs you basically do the same thing
how do we compare whether our results
are correct or not you can compare with
a closed form solution is amazing that
even a black Scholes formula is quite
complicated there are closed-form
formula for first order derivatives and
second order derivatives so here's we
just want to do a test so we go for
Delta Delta this grape is here so bcds
so I'll to check this using are closed
form close to form formula the
closed-form formula for Delta is just
off the form of a normal cumulative
distribution function and d1 where
Divine's this fraction so here we can
use a normal CDF from Sify and we can
calculate and d1
this is the result also we can use the
normal function reviewed previously to
solve this closed-form formula again
about one a seven this is a almost the
same with the Delta calculated from ad
automatic differentiation and I also did
a check for it one of the second-order
Griggs charm this is the closed-form
formula and here you need to use normal
PDF normal PDF now CDF none once again
we use the beauty and function from Sify
the result is a minus 10 4 for the charm
charm is Charma this one is in the finca
is from the Hessian matrix of first row
third column compared with this result
from ad basically the same so this
concludes this tutorial it's mainly
about the application of like how you
calculated derivatives and and the point
here is a sometimes in case that you
have some you'll behave the problem I
mean very complicated formula you
probably prefer automatic
differentiation than the numerical
differentiation because basically
automatic differentiation promises
machine level accuracy so this is a big
advantage and this is micah show you
just how to use occupy and to test it
but so i will leave the cake session
alaska so i think we can first go to the
logistic regression yeah i need to take
some time for for this one to follow GT
regression yes so make sure i think we
went very fast thank you i know we have
a very naughty latina say okay I will no
I wanted to tell you that we've i am
lee-char from a list of the geography if
you are interested in knowing more about
logistic regression also a couple of
more things alga pie is not if the ethic
is not very fast and it cannot take it
don't really hear some problem so it's
only for demonstration i would say it's
it's a very good too and also it's a lot
of companies are building after making
differentiation too so it's a good idea
to know it and try it with small
examples occupies goods or small
examples but i think it still hears a
lot of things that should be addressed
also you already talked about this but a
little bit about the advantage is that
when computing subsidy sensitivities of
option prices especially exotic options
too many parameters that this options
depend on you can use final difference
method where you have to compute the
price twice and usually compute price is
very expensive sometimes it is Monte
Carlo simulations in the automatic
differentiation allows to not compute
the price twice but though it was the
same run at the expense of taking more
memory because each information on the
node would be now taken twice more
memory to keep derivatives from of the
bodies if you don't your questions will
move on but if you have questions we can
go back to any point of this so you're
going to look for thee which is the
regression yeah okay yeah
so this is a another tutorial about
logistic regression there are basically
two parts the first part I try to build
a logistic regression myself the second
part is about how you can use it in
secular so despite its name logistic
regression is not a regression but a
linear classifier will show it why it's
a class a linear classifier let's start
from an example this is an example from
Wikipedia of the deterioration so the
problem is there are several students
and they spend sometimes the study some
are some failed some past and you want
to use this data to predict back for a
new student whether your pass or fail a
naive thought is to use a linear
regression actually this is most
tutorial about logistic regression how
those two dollars start so you can plot
use linear regression but visually it's
just not linear at all and you're
dependent variables are not even
continuous there just to the count only
takes either 0 or 1 so we need to use
another way to build a just a regression
mathematically this is averaged using
conditional probability so you have
Satan observations you want to to
calculate the conditional likelihood
function there are so if this part so
given x equals x I you estimate the
conditional probability of y there are
two ways to approach this problem
problem first you can think of it as a
Bernoulli distribution so for each
observation you can take a well UPI so
if you have this is the probability that
it will happen so the student will
succeed so you have basically MPI
and if you estimated using ml ye you get
trivial results so the PIV estimates of
P I equals 1 if the why I is 1 and the
estimates is 0 if x 0 so this way
doesn't work so you need to use another
way which is a parametric parametric
function so you should think about like
the probable the conditional probability
is based on X I so attack here is the
hours been done a student to study and
also there are some parameters I denoted
here as beta so this part is the
likelihood function to estimate this one
so basically you want to estimate beta
and x and y are inputs you need to know
the exact form of p so p is is the exact
form of the probability the trick of
here of logistic logistic regression is
we can use a logic function which maps
your data from 012 a real real number
you can also try some other link
functions for example some normal
function humility functions there's a
there's a question is like what
differences between using these
different link functions personally I
think there's not much difference but
sometimes for example you if you try
another as shape the function they might
have fat fat tails on two sides so if
you estimate using logistic regression
but they met converge at a different
speed so just as some extreme cases you
met consider not use logistic regression
and you probably need to use some like
similar function from probably
progression
so so this is about using the logic
function to do the transformation so you
map 012 are this is also called a log
off if you read some posts dolls is the
probability that that student will pass
over the probability that he won't and
not we think this line log oz can be
expressed linearly as beta prime X here
just for simplicity I beta transpose X
but precisely you want to include the
constant term so the exactly form is
beta transpose time 1x so what I'm
talking about is you should ask them in
the beta 0 plus beta 1 X 1 plus beta 2 X
2 but this is I want to show it in
matrix algebra so I just for simplicity
I denoted as beta transpose X but you
should remember that there's a constant
term beta 0 in this linear expression so
this is quick solve this equation you
can solve for P X beta so pH beta equals
this fraction this is actually a
function for logistic function know the
previous ones cut the dysfunction this
one cut logistic function now we have
the exact form 4px beta the conditional
probability we can plug in back to this
likelihood function then we have
everything so because we have we not
exact 14 p and we know X we know why the
only thing we don't know is the ass is
beta which we're going to estimate using
maximum likelihood
one more thing we need to do is to
simplify this form so px I beta is this
for line of this fraction actually you
can just start to ask teammate your beta
from an equation too but secular and
doesn't stop here in further it's
further simplify this equation actually
if you want to start from to you can
also call us plus syfy there's a sub
library called us special function or
something like that you can just cut the
buting us ipad logistic function and you
can solve this in one line code but we
need to simplify it a little bit so to
resolve this minus term x minus this
fraction that is well and we multiply
the e2 the power of theta prime X to the
denominator and nominate her we get
equation for and remember that why the
dependent variables can only take value
0 or 0 or value 1 so when it takes value
1 the second term disappear because you
have 1 minus y I if you if you have why
I equals 0 the first term disappear
because here y is 0 so why items this
line fraction term equal 0 so we can do
something like we can redefine why in
this way really fine why I such that if
wise one is still one but if Y is 0
which changes whether 2-1 so get this
equation 7 this is a pretty simplified
equation this is actually what a secular
do some and you will see it later so
secular doesn't optimize this function
it all optimized equation 7
how to maximize this one of course when
you see the Sigma Sigma simple you can
run a loop but actually it's very easy
to build in one line because you can use
vampire nanpa area or numpy matrix so
you can use matrix matrix algebra if you
read the tutorial you should take some
time to think about how they can be
written in this form so the whole
estimation part is just this one line
and this is the this is the function of
some of log log likelihood function I
use a closure here the reason I use
enclosure here is you have you need to
input X 2 hours and the why why is
whether the student pass or fail but you
also need to have another peepees the
beta the parameters because when you
want to throw your function into saipa
optimization you only want to activate t
right so that's why is your input you
only want to return the function with
parameters P so you can do this using a
closure another way to do this is using
funk tools partial I think there's
another speaker last year he's the
author of data sent from the scratch he
mentioned is how to use of funk tools to
write like functional programming and
you can use also use this but I before i
read this program i turn it and i think
there's not really big difference and
and using a closure is a little bit even
faster so i just use this one but you
can also use some funk tools partial to
build a parametric function now we can
optimize our
maximum likelihood function oh there's
one thing I want to say oh so why we
don't maximize just maximize the sum we
also take a log this is a standard way
of how to maximize value function the
reason we take log there are two reasons
first you break a multiplication term
into a center so is I mean it's not is
computationally better but another more
important reason is if you just ask you
made the sum of your log function you
met you might enter go some overflow
problem problem because free see this
one if you have very small number and
you multiply them sorry is that this is
it we don't have to make this well
because if your every term is very small
you multiply them it can be very very
small so if this term is want one your
sample size is 1000 you get one e minus
1 to the power of minus 1000 so you
probably undergo overflow so usually
this is why when people estimate mo e
they take a log no overflow means you
have very small number so something like
you you might help you might encounter
when you do some I mean numerical
differentiation for example if your
demote you nominate very very small
something like that yeah something like
that overflow not over underflow yeah
yeah not sure about the jargon Hut even
though it's not you know yeah yeah yeah
so I'm not heard about the jargon but
the point is you might suffer a
numerical you know underflow varus not
ever okay now we can estimate our
maximum function first you can just
optimize it directly without any
gradient and has
matrix that is very slow but i use it i
used a person helping algorithm from
saipa optimization and the inners over
just now they're need so I they're
basically derivative free method you can
also calculate the gradient of this
function I put this I put that function
in another Jupiter notebook because i
think this tutor is quite lengthy now
but you can try this if you want to
calculate the gradient is pretty easy
and you can use some derivative based
algorithm one in Santa is cuddle I think
it's kind of blks or something like that
oh by the way when you ask teammate this
function remember to transform your why
I to our redefined why I already find a
way I only takes value one and a minus
one so we got estimate it now here this
is the estimation part besson helpings a
butyl algorithm male side by and the
inners over here is another me it also
use other derivative based algorithm
this part put into production I'll be
very quick in this part because these
are not them the key point here so
basically I right to another function
first one in poo check I want to check
the inputs are of type numpy array so if
they are not numpy arrays for example if
they are they are stored in a list of
least I'll just throw them away this is
a little bit maybe it's not the best way
to do this but this is a tutorial follow
this but if you want to expand this
program you can use every kind of times
the second function logistic okay the
second function second part i added is i
want to make sure if the optimization
process is if the optimization process
has succeeded sometimes they fail
especially if you if you use some
derivative based algorithm for example
if you try to also include has a matrix
into optimization it can be very fast
but you can also be very unstable and by
the way this is why i use just
derivative free algorithm so we solve
this problem we get the estimated
coefficients you can check this result
from Wikipedia because the same shape
same thing it's a linear is a linear now
I'll talk about why it's a linear
classifier because we can do the rule
such that if your probability is larger
than point 5 you will you will think the
student will pass so this student will
be in let's say class 1 otherwise if
this probability is less than point 5 we
were we rejected so the student will in
class 0 but this this thing is
equivalent to just to beta transpose
tongue X and this is a hyper hyper plane
so it's a linear form so basically we
want to make sure if probability is
larger than 15 you can only see if beta
if beta prime X is larger than zero so
the problem the problem of logistic
regression is reduced to this form
sorry yeah yeah yeah you're right the a
[ __ ] function exactly so you don't you
don't need even know even need to use
Sigma main function now you just need
this hyperplane you only need sigmoid
function to optimize yeah and we plotted
this graph is a little bit tricky
actually this is a one dimensional
problem problem because you only have
one variable hours how many hours do
then spend studying but I also add the
dependent variable past example so it
seems that this is like a
two-dimensional graph but actually you
don't need this this linear line it's
lime to separate the data you can
flatten those dots onto a
one-dimensional access so basically you
just need a vault this dog here is just
this number x equals minus beta 0 /
middle 12 to you know to count to
classify your classes but if you have
many feature variables for example if
you have to feature variables to
predictors your graph is like there's a
group of dolls there's a group of those
and you separate them using a linear a
lot a linear classifier and example 2
i'll go i'll do very quick for this part
2 because this part is just to use a
more complicated example data more
complicated data so they are from UCLA
website i use a panda i download them a
web prove them and serve them in kind of
data frame so the data is about here
there's a GRE GPA rank rank is a
categorical variable so you don't want
to put a categorical variable into your
logistic regression we need to transform
to three binary variables
the fastest way to do this is use
another library called Patsy I think are
also have some similar packages like
this so you use this see rank so you
tell this library that rank is a
categorical categorical variable so it
automatically transferred them to
several urban area variables and now you
can ask teammate the result is here so
it's just an more complicated example ok
now we now we can come to secular
logistic regression this is the second
part before I talk about how you can use
this I'll introduce some concepts they
are cost function overfeeding lead
linear separability our auto
regularization and OVR technique house
function is very easy just a minus of
your maximum likelihood function
actually previously will we optimize
when we estimate our MOU estimates we
just use this we just use cost function
we didn't use a likelihood function
let's go back to hear ya so actually I
define a function like this def negate
the reason I do this is because I sie
hier only minimize the function it
doesn't maximize the function so
indicated you get cost function
overfeeding I underfeeding I think you
are familiar with them machine learning
it though it happens when you want to
model noises and the way other just
aggression in secular and deal with this
you see is to add a l1 or l2
regularization part into his calls the
function so rather than optimize the
cost function directly it optimizes the
sum of the cost of function and the
regularization term linear
inseparability there's a phenomenon that
you might encounter when you run a
logistic regression which is your data
sets are perfectly linearly separable in
this case if you run running in some
some other languages such as are you get
a warning message telling you that your
numbers are inflated because
mathematically you can prove that if
your data sets are perfectly linearly
separable your estimates tends to
converge to infinity how to do with this
problem there are several ways to
recognize a venir ability from the very
beginning the standard way is to use a
linear programming so if you have two
data sets for example a and B the
statement that they are completely
linear separable is equivalent to the
statement that there exists a vector
beta column vector beta and a number C
such that is linear approach this a
linear programming problem has a
solution solve it in some linear
programming software for example set an
optimized in Prague but probably python
is not very good at linear programming I
don't know because sometimes you need to
use a Python to call outside you know to
use an API to come out
functions probably pythons not very good
at this but if you want to use I how you
can just a staff oh oh this is a link
yeah this is a ok so for some terms
you're really tutorial you can click the
hyperlink again SI può centerline you
solve this some other ways you can for
example you can if they are perfectly
linear separable you can also try some
other algorithm like you can offend thee
on convex hull and I think there's one
way to do this really fast of time
complexity we go and log in something
like that so you use some other
algorithms to fund collect on guitar and
the separated to house these are this is
another alternative also because you
some other methods SPM but they probably
will overkill your problem because too
complicated so the best way I think is
just linear programming on yet on the
other extreme you can also have some
problems so your data sets are not
linearly separable your data says are
kind of nonlinear separable for example
like this you probably need an eclipse
to separate it at least visually
visually it seems like this if you run a
linear if you run a logistic regression
you can fail for this problem because
you just no matter how hard you try you
just can't find a line to separate this
so if you have this kind of training set
there I think at least two ways to solve
first you can rather than use beta
transpose X this a linear expression you
can use some nonlinear for for example
for an eclipse but estimate this part so
do some transformation on your future
variables also you can use our more
complicate
non linear classification method you can
use neural network but I will not talk
about this in this guitar but at least
sometimes you you probably in color this
kind of problem and if you run the gist
regression you will fail as I mentioned
before you can add our or l2
regularization for a term into your cost
of function in secular the logistic
regression minimized this to this to
formula actually are are the pictures
images not of formula i type using the
text so there are exactly from the
website so if you go to a secular
document it goes like this so you
minimize this so for the Sigma part the
Sigma part is exactly what we get in the
remember this one yeah is the seven is
this form the only difference is we have
different notation
besides this it also has a
regularization term here is the norm one
or norm too I think this is the jargon
for these two things and actually
there's a term llamada so for example
for our regularization the term is here
lambda is something called
regularization strength but when secular
try to minimize is function as you see
there's no lamina the reason is it just
divide its lambda so if that's the
inverse of lambda in the second term so
and denote this term so SI SE C is 1a
well over lambda is the root is like the
rivers of regularization strength and
encyclia and there's an argument is just
see so you can assign some values to to
to to handle overfitting or under
freaking you Stacy so you can choose
your own see but you can choose lambda
because there is a lot nola
previously a our logistic regression to
only be applied to binary classification
so you have to size 12 to two sides or
two classes let's see when's class
positive points class- but sometimes you
have more than two classes and secular
by default use the one versus Resta
technique to handle this problem so
basically if you for example if you have
three classes you first to take triangle
class as for example positive class and
you'll take the raz de the rest the
other classes here is the cross and
Squires as you treat them as class- and
you get well in your classifier do the
same thing for square crosses you get
three linear classifier and by linear
classifier I mean you actually get the
conditional probability and I denoted
here is hcc theta I X this is the
conditional probability here here i use
a different letter it's a theta but
previously we use beta is the same thing
and for a new axe a new input to predict
which class it belongs to you just need
to fund the fund I such that it maximize
your several linear classifiers
this is how a secular and by default
solves a multi-class classification
problem problem so this is a this is
this still out be very quick on this
this is to reuse which is the regression
from secular and to solve my previous
two examples as you can see there is a
see sees the inverse of a regularization
strength also we can use over different
they are difference over as I said
because essentially this is an
optimization problem that linear
probably good at handle small data set
but there are some other derivative
based optimization method and this is
run under the hood and you should read
the documents to check other method also
there is an attribute I think of
logistic regression class so you can
predict it so give your class just tells
you the class of that new student I
think this concludes this tutorial know
maybe we'll hear [ __ ] answer questions
if you have questions we'll try to
answer if not I have some more slides
about getting some generic warts on the
approach but can we have done ministry
we have questions
okay then you can continue on slides a
couple of minutes it is a bit more about
this tutorial switch with lento among
other things among other tutorials so
plan to combine alga pi tutorial and
some the when we talk about me as a
switch use derivatives methods for
smooth functions sometimes function is
not differentiable but using occupy we
can make it take Lydia videos of non
differentiable functions and still apply
methods for fun sorry okay okay I'm
sorry I will repeat so we're from occupy
we're planning to combine occupy tools
with optimization methods which are
created so smooth optimization it was
now non differentiable functions can be
differentiated basically in some cases
again this is more like educational
tools to be able to see the parameters
of optimization algorithms and see which
parameter would make you all very some
more expertise in terms of the the space
in the domain or make it more fast
converging faster and usually for your
problem you you know what you like what
kind of things you you like your
algorithm be able to do and sometimes
when you just start there optimizer you
wanted to explore the space and when you
find the spot where your optimum is you
want to live to be faster so you want
kind of want to give a hybrid with
certain teachers and then this
methodology allows you to design your
message with desire teaches
okay go back agreement i want to quote
the present is out here usually
precision think it's olympics okay we're
logistic regression can be applied in
finance very common now application is a
computing probability of default using
logistic regression for companies
I have some tutorials on this if you
like we will send it to you also created
reading assignments with logistic
regression and price prediction with
support vector machines where you
classify your signals from your prices
and this this way make greatly
predictors for future prices previous
student project in my class include
application of genetic algorithms though
equity trading presented in MATLAB
computational finance confidence also
tutorials on household transformation
and financial engineering weighted monte
carlo simulations for exotic option
pricing the same price naga pie i think
or presented in this is a course
coursework for computing sensitivities
of exotic options with non
differentiable piles and some matlab
applications Crucifier for market
signals prepare trading presented
achieve moxie student conference in
connecticut previous year also we plan
to the hero framework for taking
different activation methods with
different kinds of functions usually
there is a like well-known set of taking
functions to test accumulation methods
but for global algorithms for
globalization problems it just said that
I don't believe test functions you your
your problem could be something that the
algorithm will fail the test but it's
good for your problem so it's a kind of
fun are to give good optimization
tasting examples with special features
and we are planning to share within our
simulation system
by varying parameters of standard
optimization procedures and making
hybrids it is possible to obtain the
whole universe of methods it means that
we are not necessarily planning to code
in the optimization methods vice from
scratch but just combining them to be
able to make hybrids with desired
features as as an example now there are
metal varied immune function with random
search where you start it started from
different points in your space when you
well known standard tools such as greens
for component analysis can be written in
incremental or online form using machine
learning techniques where new date isn't
incorporate at each iteration making
such algorithm suitable for handling
information uncertainty in this case
information and tilting two pumps from a
fact that you don't have your prices
right at your hand but it comes every
minute or so you can adjust you yo
estimator mean I think that many tools
principal component analysis can be done
incrementally this will allow you to not
use covariance matrix which is very good
it will be situated on the way just a
jesting it when you date a comes along
decently such libraries of heuristic
methods were extended by multi-objective
versions of algorithms and solders this
edition was brought forth by the demand
of decision makers to use such libraries
without the help of computer scientists
what that means is that real-world
problems are usually multi objective in
nature for example if you want optimize
the portfolio you really don't care only
about the return but also care about
your risk and maybe some other things
and so it's more natural to formulate
your problem as multi objective and
previous software you get to use special
tix to make this software work for
multi-objective problems usually would
formulate your you use you must have to
say what's your main objective and then
say that other objectives would be your
constraints or maybe penalties and then
you can use of nonlinear soldiers or
unconstrained solvers if you use
penalties but usually it would require
some additional skills and you will need
help of computer scientists and you this
new multi objective software would be
easier to use for those who make
decisions who really work with data and
next step is creating tools for decision
making that I even easier to use this is
accomplished by following the natural
process of decision making in by aging
an interactive mode there is a tour
called interactive octave optimization
where you make adjustments when when you
talk to a user and new information is
accommodated or for the next solution I
have some links i actually are included
the differences from here but i have a
list of references separately if I you
need some information if you will be
interested in some information in this
message and now i also have a couple of
slides to introduce the approach that
you use but i think we're ahead of time
oh okay I'd also do you have any
questions or should I continue because
i'm not going to introduce the approach
it just i can say a couple of things
what are the advantages that it allows a
unified approach to not only create
optimization methods um let out so in
some examples will have methods which
are already known and famous is
heuristic methods but now we can derive
them in a system in the systematic way
like not guaranteed and we will see what
are the sub problems with this message
for example northern mid does not have
any memory it does not remember the kind
of next step doesn't incorporate
information about the previous good
solution but it should be the theory
suggests that algorithm should do this
then it will converge faster and behave
better so this approach is similar to
one and smooth optimization but instead
of derivative solve of the objective
function derivative of the so-called
potential function is used in
mathematics see you can see where you
actually you can make the switch using
mum GD with you for the other function
instead of the desired function when
doing integration by parts and this is
where your in simple form it the
approach could be explained with
integration by parts where the second
function integration by parts is your
density function so we basically can go
in there the approach goes like that
that problem is randomized first and
then you work not in the space of exact
values of the function but probabilities
is it so
new organisms can be constructed using
this framework by varying certain
parameters and this allows to create
automatic systems here's some soft
romantic control one of such system is
probably electronic trading so with more
or less intervention sometimes you it's
not automatic control but it should be
automatic control system systems and the
rules of the algorithms for electronic
trading should be ideally should be
adjusted by themselves but now it's not
always the throw for each system
sometimes we have to train the sole guy
dismiss every now and then and in some
cases derivatives of a very technically
defined function can be computed using
automatic differentiation which already
mentioned regard illusion of the
approaches mathematically involved but
essential part can be brought down to
the level of high school mathematics was
introduced in integration by part yes
that's all I have I have another
presentation on this approach but it's
kind of its own oh maybe next time
questions okay thank you very much for
listening